salut comment ça va regardez j'ai deux
smartphones à vous présenter on a le
nouveau poco X5 poco X5 qui est juste là
et le poco X5 pro alors si vous ne
connaissez pas coco je vous la fait très
rapidement vous allez voir au moment où
je veux les ouvrir on va se les
présenter je vais vous expliquer vous
allez tous savoir sur ces smartphones en
fait poco c'est une démarche de Xiaomi
c'est une marque qui a été créé par
Xiaomi il y a quelques années je vous
avais déjà présenté leur premier
smartphone c'était le F1 qui était très
très cool et en fait c'est une marque
qui est plutôt accès jeune qui veulent
des smartphones avec des tarifs hyper
maîtrisés tarif imbattable et c'est
souvent des smartphones qui sont
vraiment top pourquoi et bien parce que
vous avez beaucoup de specs il y en a
beaucoup sous le capot un tarif qui est
super bas ici on se parle de smartphone
entre 300 et 400 € d'ailleurs vous allez
voir un peu en dessous de 300 €, mais ça
je vous dis dans quelques instants
aujourd'hui poco est une marque qui est
toujours sous Xiaomi notamment en France
mais qui est une marque indépendante et
poco est disponible partout dans le
monde dans 91 pays autant vous dire que
si vous avez trouvé des poco à droite à
gauche vous pourrez en trouver ça c'est
vachement bien ils reviennent cette
année avec deux nouveaux smartphones 5G
le poco X5 et le poco X5 pro donc
aujourd'hui on se fait quoi et bien on
va se faire une présentation de ces
smartphones pourquoi est venu me voir en
me disant monsieur greu est-ce que tu
n'hésitez pas à présenter ces deux
nouveaux smartphones je leur dis oui
pourquoi parce que j'aime la marque
parce que j'aime beaucoup parce que
j'aime l'histoire qu'elle raconte parce
que je sais que son des smartphones sans
concession extrêmement performants et
notamment pour le gaming un tarif très
maîtrisé on n'est pas obligé d'acheter
des smartphones qu'on va payer 500
balles 600 balles pour avoir beaucoup de
performances vous allez voir qu'ici il y
en a vraiment sous le capot que ce soit
dans un smartphone ou dans l'autre donc
on va se les regarder ensemble est-ce
que vous êtes prêts moi je suis prêt
alors on y va
on va faire les choses un petit peu à
l'envers par rapport à ce que je fais
d'habitude on va regarder d'abord le
tarif comme ça vous allez savoir
exactement de quoi on parle alors il y a
deux smartphones il y a le poco X5 et le
X5 pro alors le X5 pro c'est pareil j'ai
remarqué pourquoi ils aiment bien le
jaune ça c'est vraiment le truc qui pète
il voulait mettre les specs en pleine
tronc je vous les avez là vous inquiétez
pas je vais vous les dire dans quelques
instants vous allez voir c'est du
sérieux c'est solide ça craint rien du
tout alors les deux bêtes sont juste là
il y a des différences au niveau du
design il y a des différences sous le
capot bien évidemment mais il y a des
différences au niveau du tarif celui-là
l'a regardé celui-là c'est le x5x55g il
est disponible dans deux versions on a
une version 628 à 299 euros et donc ici
en dessous des 300 balles et croyez-moi
vu ce qu'il a sous le capot franchement
c'est top et il y a également une
version 8 256 à 349 euros on rajoute 50
balles et vous arrivez là-dessus et
alors vous arrivez après sur le Must ici
c'est à dire le poco X5 pro qui débute à
349 euros en 6 + 128 et si vous voulez
monter en 8 plus 256 Go de stockage et
bien vous êtes à 399 € en gros la
différence entre celui-là et celui-là à
configuration fixer 50 balles donc ça
vaut le coup si vous pouvez ici vous en
avez les moyens de venir mettre la 50
balles en plus et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi mais on va commencer par se
faire un petit tour de magie
je pense que vous avez c'est la version
de mi-way alors ici on se parle de miway
pour poco si vous connaissez les
smartphones de Xiaomi vous connaissez
mi-way ici sont adaptés bien évidemment
à Coco sur le X5 vous avez mis 13 sur le
X5 Pro vous avez mis 14 c'est une
version au-dessus bon il y a quelques
différences quelques nouveautés mais
dans les deux cas ça fonctionnera bien
alors ça vous aura pas échappé si vous
regardez bien comme ça on a une vraie
différence de design au niveau de ses
produits le X5 va être légèrement plus
bombé par rapport au X5 pro qui lui sera
beaucoup plus plat dans les deux cas
sont des smartphones qui sont malgré
tout assez léger 180 g pour le X5 181 g
pour le X5 pro surtout ils sont très
très fin tous les deux ils font tous les
deux c'est virgule 9 mm d'épaisseur
autant vous dire que ça c'est
franchement très très fin alors moi ma
petite préférence elle va aller sur le
X5 pro non pas parce que c'est le modèle
Pro ça je m'en fous un peu mais ce que
j'aime bien ici c'est vraiment ce côté
très plat là légèrement incurvé sur les
côtés au niveau du design je l'aime bien
alors j'aime bien aussi une fois de plus
la finesse la prise en main est plutôt
bonne on fait assez bien le tour comme
ça ça va j'aime bien aussi le design
marqué poco ici alors il y a une vraie
différence parce que lorsque vous le sur
le X5 et bien c'est le même matériau en
fait c'est un imprimé que vous avez là
tandis que sur les 5 Pro voyez il y a
une vraie différence de matière entre
cette partie là et cette partie là à
côté de ça tous les deux sont plutôt
chouettes fonctionne bien alors petite
particularité je vous le dis sur les
deux smartphones vous allez avoir une
prise jack ça c'est très très cool
regardez sur l'un et sur l'autre et sur
les deux smartphones vous allez avoir de
l'infrarouge qui se situe juste ici et
qui se situe juste ici autre détail
qu'il faut connaître sur le modèle
professionnel vous avez une petite
grille là ces petites grilles là c'est
quoi c'est un haut-parleur que vous avez
sur le haut que vous n'avez pas sur le
X5 sur le X5 vous avez un seul
haut-parleur sur le X5 Pro vous en avez
deux tandis que vous voyez vous le voyez
sur le Pro vous avez deux haut-parleurs
qui est situé là autre petite différence
également sur le X5 pro votre tiroir de
carte SIM se situe juste là tu es sur le
X5 allez planquer ici sur le côté dans
les deux cas vous avez un capteur
d'empreinte digitale qui est situé sur
la tronche et qui déverrouille
extrêmement rapidement et très très
facilement donc ça c'est pareil c'est
super bien et super sécurisant vous avez
du Corning Aurillac glace 3 sur le X5 en
ligne Gorilla glace 5 sur le X5 pro et
autres trucs à connaître au niveau du
design c'est les couleurs sur le X5 on
peut retrouver bien évidemment en noir
comme ça mais également en vert et en
bleu
à 910 et on a des couleurs 10 bits sur
le modèle professionnel beaucoup plus de
couleurs en gros mais très honnêtement
lorsque vous les regardez comme ça il y
a pas de réel énorme différence autre
différence et je vous le disais au
niveau de l'audio alors je vous l'ai dit
sur le haut-parleur et la prise jack
mais vous avez en plus une petite
différence de techno ou tous 5 points
ici Bluetooth 5.2 mais bien souvent
comme c'est le cas au niveau des
smartphones la différence se situe au
niveau de la performance parce que sur
votre X5 ici vous avez un dragon 695
bien évidemment 5G gravé en 6 nanomètres
du tsnc tandis que sur le modèle
professionnel on en aura un petit peu
plus on le sent c'est légèrement plus
fluide lorsqu'on vient l'utiliser c'est
un saint dragon 778 g j'ai pour gaming
toujours de la 5G toujours du
cynanomètre toujours gravé par tsnc et
pour ceux qui le sauraient pas tsnc
c'est le leader de la gravure de puce
qui est basée à Taïwan ouais ça il faut
le savoir les techno sont les mêmes au
niveau de la RAM et du stockage c'est de
l'alpéddr 4x vous avez 6 et 8 Go de RAM
c'est la même chose et au niveau du
stockage ça lui fs2.2 128 256 une fois
de plus c'est la même chose dans les
deux cas extensible jusqu'à un terra et
ça c'est bien également il y a une
techno qu'on va retrouver sur les deux
smartphones c'est la dynam extension
3.00 en fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
va venir taper dans le stockage si vous
avez du stockage vide pour venir
augmenter virtuellement votre mémoire là
nous l'ont mis par défaut à 3 gigas pour
le monter à 5 gigas regardez on peut
choisir pour démarrer un peu le bouzin
ou à 2 giga ou alors on peut carrément
venir le désactiver bref une petite
optimisation mais qui peut être
vachement intéressante on a les mêmes
tailles de batterie 5000 milliampères
heure d'un côté et l'autre sauf qu'au
niveau de la charge et bien ça changera
un peu plus vite sur le modèle
professionnel avec un bloc de charge en
67 watts versus 33 watts sur le X5
faudra un peu plus de temps pour
recharger votre X5 de 0 à 100% en 68
minutes ici sur le X5 avec une en charge
33 watts et bien évidemment la
différence elle va se faire au niveau de
la photo parce que on n'a pas tout à
fait les mêmes capteurs sans doutera le
X5 pro sera plus musclé sur le X5
regardez ça se passe juste ici vous avez
trois capteurs photos capteur principal
48 mégapixels il vous l'écrive ici on a
également ultra grand-angle de 8
mégapixels avec un champ de vision de
118 degrés et une caméra macro de 2
mégapixels bref 2.4 tandis que vous
retrouvez à l'avant hop là regardez
juste ici une petite caméra selfie de 13
mégapixels ça c'est pour le X5 alors
fatalement plus loin on a un capteur
principal de 108 mégapixels il veut
l'écrivent ici je sais pas si vous le
voyez bien 108 mégapixels qui est situé
juste là on a toujours un ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels avec un
champ de vision à poil plus large 120
degrés pas grand chose et également la
caméra Macron de 2 mégapixels tandis que
cette fois-ci on a une caméra de 16
mégapixels au niveau des selfie donc
voilà un peu la grosse différence que
vous allez retrouver ici autre
différence entre ces smartphones et bien
sur le X5 vous pouvez venir filmer
jusqu'en 1080p à 30 images par seconde
tandis que sur le X-1 pro modèle
professionnel processeur plus performant
on pourra faire un peu plus de calcul on
va monter jusqu'en 4K à 30 images par
seconde donc en gros on aura un peu plus
sur son argent pour 50 balles de plus ça
on l'avait capté autre différence entre
ces deux smartphones et bien sur le X5
vous avez du wifi 5 du wi-fi 6 sur le X5
pro la liste de réparabilité pas le même
non plus un 7,6 sur 10 pour le poto X5
contre 7,4 sur 10 sur le X5 Pro vous
avez une double nano SIM 5G alors soit 6
5g et une deuxième SIM 5G ou alors une
sim 5g et de l'autre une extension de
stockage à vous de voir sur le X5 vous
pouvez mettre double carte SIM 5G d'un
côté et de l'autre mais ici on augmente
pas le stockage et ces deux smartphones
sont bien évidemment à vendre vous vous
en douterez vous avez une offre de
précommande qui est super intéressante
du 6 au février pour tout achat d'un de
ces deux smartphones et bien pourquoi
vous offre une pokoatch plus un bracelet
la pokewatch écoute 89,99 € et le
bracelet est à 14,99 autant vous dire
qu'ici il vous faut un beau cadeau mais
cette offre de précommande est
uniquement valable sur la configuration
de chaque smartphone en 8 plus 256 ce
qui fait que si vous voulez acheter
votre X5 en 8256 il vous en coûtera 349
euros mais vous aurez votre nom de
connecté de poco qui sera offerte avec
et sur le X5 pro en version 8 256 vous
le paierez 399 et vous aurez également
votre monde de poco offerte ça c'est
chouette une fois de plus je vous mets
les liens en bas dans la description
pour venir choisir votre smartphone dans
les meilleures conditions faites
l'intérêt principal de ces deux
smartphones c'est d'avoir beaucoup de
performances pour voir venir jouer à des
jeux par exemple ici je vais me prendre
un asphalte 9 je peux voir venir
m'amuser avec très facilement et surtout
je vais avoir beaucoup de performances
un tarif qui est très très maîtrisé
parce qu'en fait ce que fait poco ici si
vous proposez des smartphones qui sont
super intéressants pour venir jouer à
des jeux vous allez avoir beaucoup de
performances un tarif qui va être très
très maîtrisé et c'est une fois de plus
dans l'ADN de la marque venir proposer
de superbes technologies à des tarifs
très très canon et très maîtrisés donc
voyez je me marie ici hop avec asphalt 9
vous pourrez vous marrer avec tous les
jeux qui vous feront plaisir à vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez de ces
smartphones bien évidemment dans les
commentaires moi je les trouve très
chouette très canon une place bien une
fois de plus je connais la marque je
connais leur ADN je sais où ils vont je
sais ce qu'il vous propose hop là
j'arrête de jouer ton pig je me saborde
mais comme ça je peux vous parler
tranquillement donc dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez moi je trouve bien je
vous le dis mon coup de cœur il va très
clairement sur le poco X5 pro je le
préfère qu'il soit pas bombé une fois de
plus c'est une question de goût et de
couleur mais d'ailleurs vous dites moi
lequel vous préférez entre le X5 et le
X5 pro et vers lequel votre cœur va
aller s'il y en a un de ces deux qui
vous intéresse une fois de plus je vous
mets les liens dans la description je
dois me rendez vous très bientôt pour
continuer bien évidemment à parler tech
parler de smartphones mais de plein
d'autres choses et merci à beaucoup
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo je vous
embrasse à bientôt prenez soin de vous
Ciao
[Musique]